arrêtons nous un instant sur une
nouvelle manière de fraude est inventée
par un candidat au baccalauréat
d'orléans pas question pour lui
d'employer les vieux trucs du genre
antisèches dissimulé sur les poignées de
chemise ou encore formule inscrite dans
le creux de la main non ce jeune homme
et sa petite amie avait décidé
d'utiliser le dernier gadget à la mode
c'est à dire la civi c'est marcel
trillât qui a reconstitué pour vous
cette combine pas comme les autres
regardez alors roumanie deux cent trente
sept mille cinq cents kilomètres carrés
population totale 22 millions
d'habitants population active 10
millions 35
qu'est ce que tu veux aller production
alors céréales 20 millions de tonnes
dont 6 20 millions de tonnes et 6 de
pelé et 15 de maïs un set au temps passe
si vite possible
ok vas-y
est-ce que tu ton compris bien sûr j'ai
légèrement passé l'âge et dominique
tiers c'est beaucoup trop honnête pour
se prêter à une telle supercherie mais
enfin c'est à peu près ce qui s'est
passé avant-hier aux épreuves du bac bep
au lycée jean zay d'orléans le petit
malin était ainsi beast fervent il
disposait d'un émetteur récepteur à peu
près gros comme ceux ci de deux petits
écouteurs dissimulé dans une chevelure
évidemment beaucoup plus abondante que
la mienne et d'un micro gros comme un
noyau de cerise caché par un foulard
dans une voiture garée dans une rue des
environs sa petite amie complaisante
disposer de tous les ouvrages
nécessaires pour faire face à n'importe
quelle épreuve d'histoire géo du bac b
la triche était presque parfaite
presque seulement en effet il y avait
une faille n'importe quel 6 bis de
passage dans les environs pouvait
entendre plus aussi le dialogue et c'est
ce qui s'est produit
donc de chance de cibistes indiscrets et
est aussi un citoyen très à cheval sur
les principes il s'est donc aussitôt
précipité au rectorat où il a tout
raconté
quelques minutes plus tard le petit
richer été démasqués à cause aussi de
sens nous sa chevelure tout de même
votre pas bon dans tes de ce foulard
plutôt insolite par ces chaleurs
il lui en coûtera 5 ans d'interdiction
de bach
mais est ce vraiment une punition ça lui
permettra en tout cas de réviser
soigneusement pour pouvoir affronter la
prochaine fois des épreuves du mag mais
sans accessoire cela dit la journée de
demain ce sera sans doute bien pénible
pour près de 400000 lycée a qui vont
affronter les premières épreuves du bac
comme le veut la tradition c'est la
philosophie qui ouvre le programme des
réjouissances
alors en guise de conseils de dernière
minute aux candidats anne rongère se
livre à un exercice que la morale
réprouve
elle va nous dévoiler quelques recettes
de triche oui vous avez bien entendu
d'autriche des recettes tirées des
manuels à pertinents rédigé par un jeune
nantais qui n'a pas froid aux yeux
désiré audric 20 ans c'est parce qu'ils
voulaient consacrer plus de temps au
tennis qu'il a mis au point sa méthode
en vain le son pour tricher aux examens
avec ses petits camarades de classe il a
sélectionné pour nous ces quelques
conseils que la morale réprouve
complètement dépassés les mesbah les
pères de même d'ailleurs que les coups
d'oeil furtifs
le reste se passe de commentaires
vous prenez une gratte à laquelle vous
accrocher un élastique par
l'intermédiaire d'une épingle à nourrice
lancy les melons du bas jusqu'en haut de
l'épaule je triche pour en fait parce
que j'aime bien fait faire autre chose
que travailler mes examens quand je vois
arriver des sujets comme celui qu'on a
qu'on a montré des sujets complètement
stupide où il suffit juste de recracher
le court
à ce moment-là bon ben qu'est ce que je
fais moi je veux pas passer cinq ou six
heures à travailler ça ce que je fais
c'est que j'ai mes cours que j'amène
directement alors que la personne qui a
qui a travaillé pour préparer l'examen
intellectuellement d'envoi tir
absolument rien qu'est-ce que vous
conseilleriez un jeune qui débute et qui
débute conseillerais de bosser
pourquoi non en fait c'est un gag ne lui
conseillerais de démarrer avec des
méthodes très simple et très sûr est ce
qu'il ya des cas désespérés de gens qui
n'arriveront jamais à tricher web
éditeur n'arriviez pas à tricher parce
que vous rugissiez savez vous-même ne
vous inquiétez pas vous n'êtes pas la
seule dans ce cas là il ya je dirais
qu'à une bonne partie des gens qui ont
travaillé durant leur scolarité parce
qu'il n'arrivait pas à pompe et
généralement quand on travaille c'est
qu'on sait pas pompé l'éditeur de désiré
audrix est à l'amour ou entre suicide
mode d'emploi et comment se faire
réformer en vain le sont ils assument
ils disent dans cet ouvrage nous sommes
pour les enfants qui s'aiment pour les
prisonniers qui s'évade et pour les
banques qui brûle et bien comment
tricher aux examens s'inscrit de manière
peut-être moins dramatique mais à tout à
fait dans cette filiation
quelles sont les limites de la triche je
pense qu'il n'a pas ya toujours une
méthode pour répondre à une situation
donnée
alors pour réussir son bac 3 solutions
le bachotage la chance ou la fraude
d'après une enquête ils ne sont qu'une
centaine à tricher sur quatre cent mille
candidats il faut dire qu'une grande
partie des 125 millions de francs du
budget du bac sert à décourager les
fraudeurs précaution qui n'a pas suffi à
empêcher la fraude du siècle c'était il
ya six ans en 1983 cinq lycéens avaient
cambriolé le rectorat pour lire les
sujets
l'un d'entre eux témoigne ils devenus
journaliste en reportage en gouro
christophe camillieri ce midi sortie du
lycée à orléans il y a huit ans olivier
calon j'étais l'un de ses élèves un
élève dont se souviennent en cours ceux
qui passent le bac cette année
un élève qui a défrayé la chronique avec
quatre autres lycéens en décidant de ne
pas respecter la règle l'expédition a
débuté ici une nuit de juin à l'arrière
du rectorat escaladé la grille se
faufiler à l'intérieur du bâtiment par
une fenêtre ouverte puis trouver le bon
bureau ne demandera que quelques minutes
aux apprentis cambrioleurs l'armoire
était grande ouverte
zordi fit un exemplaire de tous les
originaux présent pour aller les faire
photocopier au dehors à toute allure
nous les avons ramené remis à leur place
et ni vu ni connu
on a fermé tous aucune trace pas
d'effraction les clés étaient accrochés
à l'accueil
cette année là les fraudeurs sentiront à
trop bon compte pour ne pas avoir envie
de retourner une fois encore une fois de
trop au rectorat et deux personnes qui
nous avait accompagnés et qui à l'époque
était en première et avait réussi à
avoir des sujets du bac français
malgré nos mises en garde de cet
exceptionnel coup de bol entre
guillemets de tout trouver sans se faire
repérer cette année là ils sont quand
même retourné pour faire pâmer pop un d
eux sont fait lamentablement piqué avec
les sujets aujourd'hui olivier calon
j'admets s'en être bien tiré
trois mille francs d'amendé huit mois de
prison avec sursis des petits boulots et
depuis peu le journalisme
il est le seul à parler du bape 84 les
autres eux ont préféré oublier la garde
à vue les examens interdits et les
études compromise par un coup de tête
d'adolescent
je leur ferai certainement plus mais
c'est vrai que c'était assez excitant de
rentrer une nuit dans le rectorat et de
jouer aucun regret aucun regret encore
une semaine de révisions et jeudi
prochain ce sera le début du
baccalauréat avec les épreuves de
philosophie et si les thèmes changent la
fraude s'adapte aussi mais attention les
sanctions peuvent être lourdes à
stéphanie déjà mélissa monteiro
ce pourrait être n'importe quel lycée et
n'importe quel élève
que celui qui n'a jamais triché lève la
main l'entourent autour de la carte ou
l'antisèche le procédé est sans doute
aussi vieux que l'école des générations
d'élèves ont transgresser l'interdît de
la triche dans les cours de récréation
ce n'est pas un tabou mais presque un
jeu doublait du frisson de ne pas se
faire prendre et les collines
aujourd'hui c'est mettre à profit les
nouvelles technologies comme le net
cité par exemple bâtons de colle et on
marque ce qu'on veut tuer après ça il
suffit d'imprimer les étiquettes truc
est une des meilleures astuces du web
tricheurs quelques clics et vous
choisissez la bonne marque cole tipp ex
il suffit ensuite de taper les formules
à ne pas oublier un dernier clic et
l'étiquette est prêt à être imprimé et
recoller ici par exemple sur une
bouteille d'eau ces sites tout ou partie
dédiée à la triche se multiplient
derrière je casio points comme jérôme un
tout jeune homme de 17 ans sa spécialité
le remplissage des mémoires des
calculatrices les plus utilisés par les
lycéens n'a pas besoin de tout retaper
déjà tout fait en dix minutes on peut
avoir un cours de math heure complète
sans les télés maîtrise toute une année
toute une année
la calculatrice est admise dans la
plupart des épreuves scientifiques du
bac
sauf si elle permet de communiquer mais
sur le contenu des mémoires l'éducation
nationale ferme les yeux quand même
comprendre le sujet je savais que le
cours simon
le maîtrise pas on pourra difficilement
arriver à faire quelque chose environ
500 mille candidats passent leur bac
chaque année l'an dernier seuls 150
d'entre eux ont fait l'objet d'une
procédure pour fraude ou tentative de
fraude
mais devant les commissions
disciplinaires il est alors difficile de
se justifier et les sanctions sont
parfois très lourdes comme en témoigne
claude timsit qui présidait la
commission de l'académie de versailles
toute fraude au baccalauréat peut être
lourdement sanctionnés si vous voulez la
liste des sanctions peuvent aller
jusqu'à l'interdiction définitive de
passer un examen
mieux vaut donc ne pas tricher et même
se mettre à l'abri de tout soupçon en
laissant par exemple son téléphone
portable à la maison
la réussite au bac en sera plus sûr est
bien meilleure il faut savoir que l'an
dernier 180 deux cas de tricherie de
fraude ont été découverts et sanctionné
par l'éducation nationale le chiffre est
à peu près stable depuis plusieurs
années
la punition est variable cela va de
l'annulation du diplôme à cinq ans
d'interdiction totale de passer des
examens d'état dossier signé stéphanie
davoigneau bruno martin de face un élève
appliqué de dos un tricheur son bac l'on
reconnaît l'avoir obtenue il ya dix ans
grâce à ce style aux quatre couleurs
qu'on voulait il suffit juste de sortir
la première partie est de le faire
tourner dans votre main à l'intérieur
définition ou théorème en fonction des
matières un travail minutieux pour une
activité illégale que cet ancien lycéen
pratiquer avec assiduité
c'était mon monty travail du dimanche
soir c'était à l'ag faire une pompe et
qui marche et je croyais toujours ma
pompe quoi je ne doutais jamais quoi et
je savais que ça fonctionnerait c'est
une sorte de paresse par rapport à vos
co
laurent a transformé sa trousse en
caverne d'ali baba du tricheur gomme
cutter et caire tout est potentiellement
truc abl
aujourd'hui il est employé dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique aucun regret
vous êtes un imposteur pour le bac
pour moi c'était la réussite là mais la
méthode ça ça me c'était pas un problème
quoi quelle valeur à un bac où on a
triché pour vous je me suis jamais posé
la question quoi
pourtant voilà ce que risquent elles
auront évidemment l'annulation de
l'épreuve ou de l'examen mais surtout
jusqu'à cinq ans d'interdiction de
passer tout examen universitaire ou
administratif on aimait tant qu importe
le risque
laurent est toujours aussi fier de
présenter son site internet spécial anti
sèches qui proposent même des conseils
psychologiques pour ne pas paraître
stressé et il n'est pas seul des sites
de ce genre envahissent la toile depuis
des années la justice ne s'est jamais
penché sur la question
à côté des traditionnels antisèches
apparaissent les nouvelles technologies
en région parisienne 55 fraude concerne
l utilisation de documents personnels 8
les téléphones portables 6 les changes
de brouillon entre candidats pourtant le
jour de l'examen
les consignes sont claires faisait tous
vos sa queue devant un bureau
les téléphones portables sont interdits
téléphones portables qui permettent de
communiquer avec l'extérieur mais aussi
de stocker des informations sous forme
de sms
et comme ils sont de plus en plus
miniaturisés ils sont de moins en moins
repérables fouille pas les élèves non
peut toujours leur demander ici on a un
soupçon de nous assurer qu'ils n'ont
aucun instrument et le vérifier en 2004
sur 500 1000 candidats seuls 182 ont été
sanctionnés pour fraude
mais combien de tricheurs n'ont pas été
repérés dans votre scolarité triché lors
d'une dissertation ou d'une
interrogation match oui et bien n'ayez
pas de complexe puisqu'on vient
d'apprendre grâce à une étude que plus
de 70 % des élèves reconnaissent avoir
utilisé des antisèches ou avoir regardé
sur la feuille du voisin vous allez le
voir ce ne sont pas forcément les moins
bons élèves qui sont les plus inventifs
loin de là mallory à uno clément le goff
jean françois mayet
en cette période d'examens comment ne
pas évoquer le travail le stress la
concentration mais également la triche
selon une étude menée en 2009 auprès de
1800 étudiants elle s'avère massive
cet étudiant sur dix avoue ainsi avoir
déjà triché au cours de leur scolarité
antisèches réponse soufflé aux voisins
sont les plus fréquentes les méthodes
par est rodé c'était plutôt dans un
examen où j'avais pas bien révisé et
tous mes voisins c'était exactement la
même chose donc on a mis en commun nos
connaissances pour pouvoir arriver à
faire quelque chose à écrire au moins
quelque chose sur la copie c'est des
grands classiques 1 c'est la feuille
tombé sous les fesses et tout ça tu vas
en ressort le jour de l'examen mais dans
les brouillons ça passe tout seul on
s'échange les brouillons bam a lancé
l'iphone en fait tu prends en photo tac
peach et amy sur ton iphone et tu
regardes les réponses pendant tapas
choix banaliser la triche seulement 5 %
des élèves ont contourné les règles en
primaire mais 48% n'ont pas résisté au
collège 36% au lycée 11 % des étudiants
triste encore souvent ceux qui ont
commencé tôt alors qu'ils fraudaient
pourquoi paradoxalement à l'université
ce sont souvent les meilleurs bacheliers
qui vise l'excellence pour les plus
faibles
le jeu en vaut vraiment la chandelle par
ailleurs les fille serait plus honnête
que les garçons 35% d'entre elles
affirment n'avoir jamais triché contre
25% pour eux enfin on triche plus dans
les filières scientifiques et
technologiques qu en droit ou en lettres
pour les auteurs de l'étude beaucoup de
fraudeurs n'ont pas forcément conscience
de mal agir beaucoup aussi ignore ce
qu'ils risquent avertissements exclusion
est par exemple au bac
l'interdiction de le repasser pendant
cinq ans le bac maintenant coup d'envoi
demain pour des centaines de milliers de
lycéens avec l'épreuve de la philosophie
et cette question qui revient avec plus
d'insistance encore cette année comment
lutter contre la triche les antisèches
sont passés de mode désormais ce sont
les téléphones portables et les mp3
qu'il faut surveiller reportage julien
pelletier
violaine vermot go il y avait les
antisèches au fond de la trousse ou plus
difficiles les théorèmes dont le stylo
dans la panoplie du tricheur voici le
téléphone portable
dernier jour de cours pour ces terminal
devant leur lycée tous sont un téléphone
entre les mains et certains l'utilisent
pendant les contrôles pour chercher
cours et corrigé sur internet
google on tape le nom du sujet ou de
l'exercice et on apprendra potes sur
google il ya tour tu te mets au fond de
la classe et le sort discrètement
c'est pas compliqué je me retrouve comme
ça le téléphone juste derrière comme ça
je regarde tac tac tac je note
j'aurai les éléments les plus importants
et ses fesses dans la poche cette jeune
fille a même installé une application
spécialement pour tricher elle a
photographié des dizaines de courts
comme ça mais pas question de l'utiliser
demain le bac c'est trop sérieux
c'est trop dangereux les fraudeurs
risquent même plus gros jusqu'à cinq ans
d'interdiction de passer le bac
seuls deux cents dix neuf candidats sur
600 milles ont été accusé de triche en
272 en 2010 même si la fraude est
marginal la hausse est là et elle est en
grande partie lié au nouveau téléphone
bien voulu déposer tous vos sa queue
devant un bureau
les téléphones portables sont interdits
à l'examen c'est comme ça le portable
doit être rangée or la triche existe car
les candidats ne sont pas fouillés et
peuvent quitter la salle pour aller aux
toilettes
ce prof de maths et surveillants au bac
et comme ses collègues il se sent démuni
face au téléphone à part la solution du
brouillage des centres d'examen je vois
guère autre chose
j'en vois guère autre chose surtout si
il ya encore une continuité dans ces
réductions de ses de ses outils de plus
en plus petit les montres dès qu'ils y
ont accès à l'internet à quelques rares
exceptions dans les prisons ou les
salles de spectacle le brouillage des
ondes est interdit par la loi
la solution est peut être ailleurs
depuis quelques années les épreuves
demande moins de parker et plus de
réflexion et la téléphone et internet ne
servent plus à rien voilà la solution
c'est aussi de ne pas souhaiter tricher
peut-être
[Musique]